olá tudo suave que quem fala em mudar
que seja muito bem vindo já mais um
vídeo eo estrago de qe2 nights leixões
está um fã do game facchinetti fred e
pelo que vi no bangu shopping oferece
banho lista banho se estudando eo buraco
é que não é barato escuro para next
câmera prêmios caio que estamos
comandante que só fugiu estabelecem ao
meu tá muito realista isto 3d e mel
aí você entender acho que ela vai
juntando em 2d e matrix é o boni branco
eo fred preto é isso aqui é um quadrado
verde supostamente um deus tounet
exatamente na só que nós temos aqui para
os salvos como faz netflix que aquilo é
um porco
o fogo vejam como está e alistamento
também alguém saiu dali uma bóia tac tac
para onde estou é a minha sala e lá
embaixo o fred está lá em cima por isso
não é preocupante nec outro eu passo por
aqui
aí eu posso não pedras 12 como é que o
cara logo que ele esteja pronto já que
ela eo garoto teria aqui e eu não sei
jogar stan lee gol posso esconder
debaixo da mesa o que quer dizer que vai
perceber que alguém método de ensino a
câmera eye to eye ato de cura através
dele e eu ainda não conquistei o hype
mouse vai pra flash lite já fez foi não
funciona ou cai são duas da manhã em
díli o fred branco e o zecão enquanto
hoje as câmeras eu posso aceitar o que é
uma coisa boa
temos um público que tem de um cãozinho
que não há na lei penal de um barulho
mas nunca ouvi um barulho para o pb não
sai daqui com a idéia de desculpas da
mesa isso vi que o futebol é alguém da
aqmi dúvida houve expansão em tentar
aqui ou não
eu posso ir longe aqui eu acho que
precisa ainda passar à história
quem sabe esta mesa não está tranquilo
no fredman coisa do lula em 2002
ai ai alguma coisa acontecer christie's
corda
ouvi o avião no início o fred que falou
pouco discreta explica na ponta do lápis
preta
não só isso ok eu nem ninguém
supostamente que o elevador né eu não
sair aí está sendo aqui é isso luxa
funciona aqui e eu caí lá o fundo não
está ninguém né e eu não vou perceber
isto eu já não perceber nada eu não
percebo os comandos está confuso pra mim
basicamente tem que ficar atenta a esta
porta é esta porta e aquela pilha de
lixo é uma porta mas tem que ficar
atenta que também por dizer qual já não
sai tudo perdido é que meu existem isto
é muito grande pra mim o que
supostamente nenhum de um cio ainda que
o boni branco 101 mas quem está aqui
aí houve um riso as sete décadas e de
quebra ainda quebrou ganhando aqui se
demonstra se nos pretas freitas preta
eu acho que não é por um boi bumbá
apoiando aqui também o seu fado eu acho
que não preciso desse números porque
esta zona é bastante claro até eu não
sei se dá pra perceber mas insistiu que
tem muitos humanos é muito confuso é que
o porco a um tac
ela ainda está longe de mim não é
preocupante ok este mundial já está
quase perm nesta sala não está ninguém
no escuro
é muito difícil ok vamos lá começar
então nós temos aqui um boné branco
temos é que é um preto em cima oca e
temos alguém mais além ao fundo eu
também me incluo nesse cara
ok mas aqui em baixo que nós temos ainda
por cima as teclas são todas diferentes
eu tenho de usar o rato o teclado mouse
teclado mouse teclado mas é como eu é
muita teclas brasil era ordem qualquer é
que também toca está tudo tranqüilo
aparentemente está tudo bem
a cair aqui é que nós temos que fazer as
primeiras luzes não ia ceder perante
tanto a até que o teclan
o erro né após correr efeito
ramos preto e off the office posso
voltar eu posso correr do posto meu a
sério este o capital só tá é muito
confuso não está no paulo este é o
primeiro jogo que o vasco pelo menos e
conseguiu fugir do posto voltou o
veículo escrita em pedra eu posso estar
discutindo após fechar o scouting mas
nem este capital está muito bom
aí a luz piscou para que ela ganhou acho
que nós temos aqui nada está tudo
tranquilo e desfrutar o fundo nada ok
vamos lá ver as câmeras quanto para os
combater mesmo sentimento que alguém vai
aparecer agora não houve qualquer coisa
que me move direito tac olha aí
ai ai eu cozinho lindo eu sei cantar
aqui ela ganha não vou sair daqui né não
vou ficar aqui até ficar de salto a 100
quilômetros o matrimônio iam vender
direita eu sei que eu vendi direito à
vida que alguma coisa eu você e você eu
não aguento mais ficar aqui vai assim
lúcio sai alguém sendo luxo a cair
ninguém está aqui ver o coronel fundando
a ninguém está aqui alguma coisa não
aqui ninguém é o fundo eu acho que vou
lá ver eu vou lá estar aqui alguém que
faz suas cortinas
alguém abriu as cortinas alguém abriu só
quem curte na volta por trás
ai ai pela símbolo só que respeita ao
fundo do túnel não está ninguém e também
eu sei dizer se são todos saibam o preço
da mesa ninguém está aí fora está muito
suspeito é esse respeito
ninguém está lá fora e ninguém se
mostrando as câmeras e eu aqui era para
eu ir
ficou tudo preto porque consegui passar
quase que passaram a primeira noite eu
nem fiz nada meu eu nem fiz nada mas
pronto essa é a técnica é ficar baixo
também essa até ficar de pé e se
esconder noite mas também tem mais
difícil né agora já não presta ajuda em
s
é só na primeira noite meu eu não
escutei as teclas
ok eu usei o italiano é também mais do
que a que mais cai é supostamente é
adiantar é isso aí era querida rúmen
supostamente um deus sol ou então por
que nós temos parte sem serviço eles
espero que aquilo em cima da mesa que
parece um frio arraial de ensino eo
voucher daqui vai sair sai da equipe era
assim nas lutas contra o arizona barak
ao estilo que eu acho que foi o bubble
boy calma vai lá pra frente eu acho que
alguém já viu o zagueiro igor da faixa
essa pouca volta para trás após o fim do
ano aqui
o filme foi um barulho de metal fundido
enfrentar o fundo a cair eu acho que
ninguém eu vi que multiplicado ou não aí
não se está em ordem o biochip carmen do
piauí
eu não sei se ele ficar aqui nós
conseguir mas eu acho que é melhor ficar
aqui não é
foi assim que eu passei primário não é
que assim que vou passar a segunda eu
acho que você é melhor crescer pouco não
está preparado e eu não sabia eu saber
quem é não tava que eu sabia mesmo de
tirar os fones né
o pessoal vai ficar porque não quer não
quer ficar mais isto é deixar os seus
comentários com ajudas sugestões como é
que eu só vi isto porque eu não estou
triste mas só se sobrar alguma coisa
comentem e ajudem escrever bem mais
vídeos de 2007 rochom também né
mas só espero que vocês tenham estado já
sabem como foi que tudo fique bem até
aproximar